Wow.
Well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
If I were the poop pile,
everybody wants,
everybody wanted to tell
everybody
hi everybody wanting to admit that
you guys had it heil feces in your backyard
like this.
Okay?
We should on that thing for a hundred days in row.
People from all over the apartment complex.
We shit their
neighborhood kids.
What?
I don't think you should read that
everybody.
Everybody.
Oh my God.
That was a pile of fun by um,
Dj Orlando where I got it.
I liked it.
Especially because you're a big liar with his poop pile.
Nonsense.
What do you mean?
Everybody knows it's a lie?
No,
no.
You've had me try.
You've tried to fool me for the last 11 years.
No,
it's true.
It's not true.
Yeah,
it is.
Um,
give me one person who actually was on the pool pile that pooed on the pool.
That's not one of your best friends.
Who Lies?
Well,
they're all people that live there,
Babe.
Okay,
well then let's call those people up.
How do we find them?
Still demands a producer.
He can find anything.
Okay.
How do we find people?
It's the internet speed.
How are we going to find their names?
I don't remember the year,
my junior year of college
a long time ago.
For you to look who's talking.
You gotta be kidding me right now.
Yeah,
but you look older than me and you act older than me.
I do look older and I'm much more mature.
But that's not true.
Yes it is.
You're not more mature.
Yes.
You're a child.
No,
no,
no.
Don't go into,
so what do you mean?
I'm so much more mature than you know.
You're nuts.
Why?
I'm more 10,000 times more retreat.
Yeah.
Your child.
I'm a grownup.
Stupid.
Your beard smells and I smelled what you ate yesterday.
We're going to talk about that.
Should some natty was great.
Thank you everybody that came out to Liberty Township,
liberty township,
very,
very north of Cincinnati.
How was that new club?
It's beautiful.
Yeah,
it is beautiful.
It's why better than a Kentucky Fort that was,
uh,
that was a goddamn shit dog shit pile.
And that was a poop pile.
Bad luck.
It wasn't my favorite.
It wasn't my fate.
And attracted the riff Raff.
Lot of drunks.
It was really rough back of the animals in that area.
People vomit and that show room a few times on me.
I had a tweaker run up to the stage.
So if you want to,
if you're trying to get your act to dumbed down,
do some spots,
it would happen through the shows and all of a sudden you're like a final show.
You're like,
oh my God,
I'm fucking retarded now.
You guys like to Fart and shit.
That's our show by the way.
But we do it sophisticate,
right?
We're sophisticated corridors and stuff
this weekend.
How she,
I'm in Manley a whole sometimes called San Diego.
Every show is sold out except for the show we added,
they added a show Thursday at nine 45 so if you want to still come to the shows
that the American comedy company,
Gaslamp district,
downtown San Diego,
is that downtown?
That's where all the people gas line,
the gas lamp.
Anyways,
uh,
we added a show Thursday
last time.
Kyle kinane ended up at a Tgi Friday's.
Remember?
That was fun.
It's really fun.
That was our most fun time of that week.
Um,
so thank you.
Everybody.
Please come out.
And then Saint Louis tits the next weekend.
Good one.
Yeah.
21st 22nd,
23rd of July.
And then,
um,
oh,
there's a couple of things that change.
I got a,
um,
I'm not allowed to announce why yet,
but I had to move some things,
but just to let people know what's happening.
I can pull this up.
Oh,
I'm still coming to Magoo bees.
Joe Cow such in Timonium,
Maryland.
Um,
that's the Greater Baltimore area.
So ball's in whores.
Please come see me then come on our bus.
Um,
Ohio August 11 through 13 and coming there,
um,
let's see.
Charlotte,
North Carolina or how many zone?
October 14 through 14,
15.
And then I had to move Jude or titties.
Um,
and the reason was because of this thing I'm doing that haven't been given
permission to talk about yet,
but we moved it to October 27th through 29th,
so I'm still coming.
It's just about six weeks later,
um,
laughing derby and loose her tits.
Phil,
Kentucky Number 10,
12,
10 to 12.
And then the Trocadero theatre and fill her up.
Delphia Pennsylvania.
We added a show.
It is November 18th that is on sale now.
Gene's what'd you got?
All right.
Uh,
I go on tour.
I do one nighters now.
September 27th and the Seattle,
Washington at the to come on your comedy club.
Uh,
Stanford 28th Shortland Oregon at the helium comedy club.
What pork?
Them horrors again.
Well,
for what?
For Portland.
So that's a stretch that was submitted by Mike silver fork them whores again.
Horrors it pretty good if you say it like,
yeah.
Pork.
The horrors again.
The Moore's again.
Horrors again.
Yeah,
I got it.
That's a good one.
Thank you.
October 4th uh,
Dallas,
but what would that be?
Fallis Salus Tay House at Hyenas Comedy Club.
October 5th huge come Texas at the secret group.
October 23rd I'm million floppy tits,
Indiana.
Oh yeah.
We also got submitted Indian apple tits.
That's idea in apple,
j c and then October 24th Cincinnati,
Ohio and go bananas.
My favorite obviously for obvious reasons.
Yeah.
I'm going to commemorate the Cincinnati foreign,
I'm going to try to stay at that hotel,
hopefully.
Yeah,
we'll see.
yeah,
absolutely.
Guys,
I get the tickets now for all those shows@thousandranchdotcomthousandranch.com.
Also,
if you do your shopping on Amazon,
please use our banner at http colon slash slash www dot your mom's house,
podcast.com and click on the Amazon banner at the bottom of the homepage.
A yeah,
all your shopping helps the show.
Um,
and also of course we have bonus episodes,
bonus content,
owner episodes or episodes.
Uh,
uh,
patriot,
Patriot now.com.
Slash mom.
I like when you say it under your breath,
more angry or Patriot,
um,
to 12 times touch that shit.
Um,
we have a lot of fun stuff there.
So patriotic and puts that down.
Patron and that kind.
Slash mom.
Uh,
this week we have some visitors coming to our home,
so I'm going to try to get them in here to do some bonus content.
Boner.
Yeah.
Phone or content.
Are you going to say who they are?
You can keep it a secret.
Oh wait,
we can say I guess,
right?
Yeah.
Mario Lopez is coming.
My Sister Maria.
Ah,
um,
God.
Um,
and then uh,
later,
well actually next week got top dog and Charo are going to be here.
It's a huge family event coming up.
Yeah.
So,
and then my cousins are coming up from Riverside,
not that far.
Yeah.
My aunt,
the plan's going to be here.
Guys.
You can be crazy.
But um,
I'm excited to talk to Mario Lopez.
We haven't talked to her in awhile.
I know on the show we've got to get her in here.
Just kind of a to say shit.
Yeah,
we'll talk some shit when we talk some shit.
Talk some fucking shit.
I'm still afraid of her cause she um,
she's very active and we're not,
I know she's gonna like be doing wind sprints around her.
We be like,
oh my God,
Thomas Fat Burns Fat.
Everyone's fine.
You guys are fat.
What are we gonna do today?
Like you're looking at it.
I know you keep worrying about that cause I,
what are we going to do today?
Because we don't do much,
like can we just hang out with her maybe in like do or show,
you know what I mean?
We,
we're,
we're not like big,
just,
we don't do a lot of activities for the sake of doing activities.
Right.
We don't have that kind of time.
She's like that.
Yeah.
She's a kind of person like I have to go to Starbucks.
No,
she also are fine.
You can't tell her there's no time.
She'll be like,
no,
there is time.
Yeah.
We're just going to run ourselves into the ground.
Like you and I,
we put the kid down like,
let's watch TV now.
We don't like cook full meals and you know,
I helped build up my calculator probably.
Yeah.
No,
that'd be fine.
She should definitely.
Yeah.
And then let her hang like the lights in the backyard too.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Do everything.
Let's just make her do her errands or working in downstairs.
Um,
hey,
what's up everyone?
Today I'm going to talk about just steroids.
Make your balls straight.
The answer is yes,
they do.
Let me throw this at you.
Is that really a bad fucking thing?
Don't bring anyone love loving to this.
Well,
welcome
to your mom,
so I'll shoot,
shoot,
shoot.
Christina,
are you shaking your head?
I know what's going on.
You know what it is.
It's later in the day.
Then we'll usually tape.
You're a little tired.
Have some brown diarrhea and this will make you feel better.
You're,
you're used to drinking this instead of water.
Anyways,
so
fucking water champion.
He sabotaged me.
I brought up that bottle water and then you cleaned it like it was yours.
Meyer,
you were going downstairs.
I asked you to bring water please.
He couldn't carry everything in my hands,
but if you are such a water person,
you would already have taken care of your own needs.
What are you talking of?
Water.
Well,
you wouldn't pass.
Pass it off on me.
I can't ask you to bring water.
Not if you're a water champ.
You should just have it up here.
Oh my God.
You're such a jerk to that.
Tom,
can we please talk about,
we'll get into this guy.
I think it's amazing.
It's got,
it looks good.
This is a natural,
natural.
The Sun was in the health.
She's someone's way in the house.
But you don't think it's amazing when you came home yesterday from your trip and
I smelled your beard and I guess what you had for dinner the night before cause
I hadn't showered since cause that went from show to the hotel and I had an
early flight.
Right.
And you're like,
you put your nose in my beard and you go,
he had meat,
you know last night I did.
Yeah.
That was so cool that it stays trapped that long.
I would think that it was like,
you know,
a few hours,
right.
It stayed in there for 1516 hours and you flew and you woke up and you ate other
garbage.
Probably had Bojangles in the airport.
I didn't have Bojangles.
You don't like to get that?
No.
Before you fly six in the morning.
I don't ever like,
as much as I am somebody that will eat definitely garbage sometimes I never do
the morning like Mcdonald's.
Like when you see people just lined up at 5:00 AM,
you know,
who's doing night pretty bland or if anything,
I'll go to one of the airport restaurants for breakfast so you can get an actual
a cooked breakfast but not you can't do.
And the real salvage are the people that bring the bags of fast food on the
flight.
You fucking asshole on the 7:00 AM you could smell fast food.
You're like,
dude,
you're going to eat that on this flight.
Oh,
I smells like farts to cause it's an egg sandwich.
Planes.
Toxic parts.
Yeah.
And I realize why is it something that sounded good?
Like you know those,
she's the Hash browns.
I like fire.
I want those,
you know?
Anyway,
I thought that was just a real testament to my talent as a beard.
Yeller
that I could tell you what you had for dinner the night before.
It was impressive.
I'll give you that.
Yeah,
maybe that I hate you in a lot of ways,
but if that was impressive.
Okay.
Yeah.
People are really listening right now.
I don't realize that they missed a burb that you did because it's cut out of the
show now,
but when you burp during our Goddamn ads,
I have to cut it out and um,
I,
I'm sorry.
Does that make you feel better?
A little bit.
Yeah.
That one is,
it's a good point.
It is.
Here's what needs to happen.
You need to have a nap today.
You need to eat nice things and he needs your balls melt because you're a little
intense and it's cause your balls are full.
Yeah,
it's true.
You're all fired up because we haven't done it yet.
You just got home.
I had to go to the lady doctor this morning,
so we bang it out yesterday and now you're all backed up and you're angry as
fuck.
And I know
that make you feel better.
Sure.
I like you more.
Okay.
Yeah.
I love you Tom,
that I'd be to want to talk to me about one of those.
See the steroid guy?
Yeah.
I haven't seen all of these yet.
I want to see what he talks about.
Is it such a bad thing that you're bothered?
That's a great idea.
It is something I'd never considered.
Does it suck to have your,
does it suck to have your balls shrink?
I don't know.
I know he,
it's kind of,
you've never actually heard that,
are you?
I've never heard that.
Ever heard of that or like what's so wrong with that?
Yeah.
Visually and aesthetic,
which are the same thing I'm looking at.
Would you prefer to see hang lower than the ball or fucking ball and you're
lower than the day dipping lower than the balls.
Look at that voice.
Whoa,
whoa.
Her wanna see her really.
Her Dick hangs lower than her balls.
You look at her and you're like,
okay.
And she goes,
yeah,
hang lower than the ball.
The balls.
Wow.
Because you see,
uh,
for our listeners,
yeah.
Cause uh,
you know,
a woman with a,
with a lot of cleavage showing clearly into fitness as well.
And she got them hard titties.
Like when the,
when the days my daddy's no more,
it's just hard.
Basel got the packs.
He has completely unnatural this dude.
It looks like somebody drew him,
you know,
like it's crazy.
It's like a sketch of a muscular person.
It's comical.
It's ridiculous.
So she,
well,
how do you feel about that question?
Uh,
I,
I mean,
I don't,
I think it's okay.
Like on either end,
it's too extreme.
If it's gotta be one or the other.
If the balls are too small,
because I don't,
I don't know.
What about his question?
Would you rather see balls hang lower than the deck or a deck hang lower than
the balls?
Nothing.
I've thought about,
think about it.
Now.
I don't give a fuck.
Is that enough of an answer?
Like,
yeah,
that's a legit answer.
No.
Why?
Because they all come in different shapes and flavors and sizes.
Flavors.
I care more about the taste.
Right.
You're worse.
Jesus.
Well,
because when men get older,
don't the nuts kinda hang lower than the dick even seeing balls hang lower than
the deck for the last 11 years.
But I was saying is when you're aligned and,
yeah,
see I don't play,
I don't think about that.
When you watch on your online on red too,
when you're googling like you don't see the out there.
Um,
what do you mean you don't see it?
That cause they're usually inside of somebody like,
I don't know,
but it starts out like when they,
they do the UNZIP,
right?
And the girl's like,
Ooh.
And he's like,
yeah,
bitch.
Yeah.
Like that part,
those big,
all the thongs hang below the balls.
Right.
See,
I don't notice that to me balls or like an afterthought.
They're really for,
at least for me,
they're just not part of the primary.
They're just in the background dude.
Like I don't even consider them really well.
I would say that I've seen you consider mine,
so I feel like you're not being totally honest.
Transfer were married.
I don't do that for everybody.
Jesus,
you don't have,
somebody was asking me to describe you.
I'd say,
well she's a ball of fishing.
You consider the balls when you're married because that's,
but you're always like
game because we're married and I got to keep it interesting.
But for every other guy that I'd been with,
who cares.
Right.
I don't next clip here.
Oh,
of course you would rather see it dig,
hang lower than the balls.
Now some guys are blessed and that big fucking Dicks and some guys are fun and
have little motherfucking days.
So the guys that have balls and hitting down lower than their day,
I would think they wouldn't want their fucking balls to shrink.
This guy's a genius.
Yeah,
this guy is pretty cool.
Then you know what I love too and I really saw my balls to shrink to hold on.
I love these guys that are super aggressive,
like whatever.
It takes like the,
it's so dumb.
Like really whatever it takes.
Huh?
What's a real gym rat attitude is about.
It's about like,
I work out all fucking day.
I get it.
Yeah.
Sorry.
So what did,
what did you just say though?
I'm sorry.
I um,
I dunno what I just said.
Hey Dick and the,
he said it baby.
I didn't say it,
but you said you're not sure if you want the Dick to be no,
I said I don't want my balls to shrink.
Yeah,
I think it's not healthy.
No.
Why would I want them to shrink?
I think it's not good for you.
I think it,
it doesn't it decrease your,
uh,
your testosterone?
No.
What happened was decreased burden to have such a,
I think a jump in testosterone that your body's natural testosterone output
decreases,
right?
Because you're pumping yourself with unnatural amounts.
Your natural production of testosterone goes like,
oh this is way too much inside of me.
Goes down.
So you test these drink too.
That's terrible.
Yeah.
I mean look,
that's a,
you know,
price you pay for looking for,
looking at totally and like looking so awesome and perfect like this Guy Jesus.
Cause this isn't heavily the veins and the chest and the shoulders.
To me personally,
and this is just me personally,
this never looks,
it doesn't look good.
This guy is in a lot of pain though.
You can tell.
I mean of course this is the same as seeing like a 500 pound person.
You know,
you go like,
oh that person's in a lot of pain.
Of course.
Yeah.
I mean,
and you can tell why a lot too.
Like the voice is a voice of pain.
Yeah.
Danny Bonaduce.
Hard living.
The,
he's got the jet black.
No,
unnatural hair is hair.
Um,
yeah,
like the tattoos that are just running all over that like nothing about this guy
is balanced.
No,
because honestly having a balls hanging down below your Dick is not the best
look and it only makes your dick look even smaller than it is.
So you just heard it from a hot girl and I give her a ticket.
Every fucking girl out there was going to say the same fucking thing.
They'd rather see the tick hang lower than the balls.
Now,
here's what I do love about this guy.
Everybody in this world,
you always make you,
you have to live with your situation and you have to make your situation right
in your mind,
at least acceptable does that.
Or you end up hating everything.
Right.
You hate yourself.
This guy,
obviously he hates that his balls or shrunk really small,
but he's right.
He's telling the story of no.
Awesome.
Yeah.
He's seen her at the gym.
Look at the way she looks at him with like pity.
You could see it in her face,
like it's like a troubled,
Kevin's got probably and he,
yeah,
of course.
And he was like,
what?
I say would you want the cock or the balls small?
And she's like,
okay,
the Dick Hanging.
And now it's like his,
his story that he wants to believe he's putting it out there.
He doesn't believe what he's even selling.
Yeah,
I agree.
He's working by making every fucking girl out there once small balls like no,
they don't do,
no,
no.
I can't,
you know,
now that I do think about it,
I think a nice pair of big slobbers like go nuts.
It's a sign of male virility.
You want a guy with low hangers with low hanging fruit because that means he's
been around.
He can,
he's fertile.
Yeah,
he's pumped loads.
That's what you want.
And you love that ball slab.
You're always like,
slap those balls against behind.
Right?
Yeah.
I forgot about that part.
You're always like gimme that boss.
Huh?
Have I said that before?
Yeah.
Cause he got a tiny little marbles.
You can't do that.
He can't do that.
I got a big Ole hangers on me.
Do you know God didn't give me a real great Koc.
They gave me the balls to make up for it.
That's true.
That's not true now.
But Your Dad's got,
oh my God,
we got to see my dad's balls.
A Guy,
you know,
but I want you to actually hold them this time.
Do you think you'd let me know?
But I think if I was like,
you've got to show Kristen in your roles.
He'd be like telling me,
okay.
Yeah,
I think so too.
He would show me.
We could not tell your mom no,
but I would want him to bend over so you could see him from behind.
That's the angle.
Have you seen him from behind?
Because I've seen them change.
You know,
it's like I've been in the room when he's like
putting on underwear and I'm like,
oh my God.
He's like worst few things like what are you doing?
I'm like,
look at your balls.
Balls hangs so low.
Very few men look good from that angle.
By the way,
even if you're super fit like a even a really fit guy bent over and you see the
balls hanging,
it's,
we'll talk about them when they're,
when they come.
It's not sex.
Hopefully we'll do a segment on his balls.
What does your mother feel has we don't want to get into,
that'll be a new thing because I think what we can try to do is just speaking to
them for half an hour or just talking about farts.
Shits and balls to really loses her mind
really,
really has a low tolerance.
Very low.
She'll stay on the line a little longer if I'm in the room.
Yeah,
like cause then shawl but I'm going to put them right here.
I think that's the way to do it.
She's going to hold scout base
please.
Maybe 20 to 30
Scott.
He's so 80% at.
Can I tell you though?
It would be more weird to me to see a man with tiny shrunken nuts,
horse and nice hangers.
Then,
you know,
you could tell you,
so it was like,
look,
you can work out here for a month for free if you just do my cock and ball
video,
because it's clearly she's coached into saying whatever.
She just takes pity.
I think that is a pity because he faced.
Do you know anybody that likes small ball?
The big balls?
No.
Oh,
I've talked to girls with anything like balls.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm sure there's the room.
Other phase.
Don't drag balls.
Drag.
Who's been telling you that?
Couple chicks.
I know
couple of girls.
what girls.
You don't know any girls beside your sisters?
I'm sure she'd be like,
it's like,
I mean,
I fucking love all of it.
Like that whole thing.
She animal
love balls.
I don't mind balls.
I,
it's just neither here nor there.
It's a nonissue for me.
It's like I'm on the salad.
Right,
right,
right.
Who Cares?
I can eat salad with or without the crew time.
20 to 30% is probably a good fucking thing.
In fact,
not probably.
It is a good fucking thing.
The higher your balls are,
the bigger your fucking Dick Looks.
I'm really into this.
He's really selling it,
but there's guys out there that are like,
Yep,
I'm on board.
My board anyway,
Dave,
look back.
But they have to,
if you're a,
for the Jews had liked this,
you got to start being like,
hey,
it's a good thing of,
you know,
you're finding the process.
Find The rain.
Yeah.
Life gives you lemons and you got a get fucked up on the weekends.
Well,
I'm just telling you I chill.
Shit.
How the fuck it is and my opinion is I would rather have my balls shrink 20 to
30% and my balls have shrunk 20 to 30% so my dick looks even bigger solo.
What the fuck is the problem here?
Right.
That was the best laugh I've ever heard.
Right?
Oh,
the problem here?
Yeah.
Oh
boy.
What's the 5%
the problem here?
God,
I'm going fucking take this guy and she doesn't want to be in the video.
Yeah.
She's like,
uh,
are you trying to get me?
Because I feel like there's also,
he asked her to do this video to see if like talking about his dick and balls.
We did entice her.
Maybe she's like,
yeah,
she's like a nice girl.
That works then.
Yeah.
She's like the front desk girl checks people in.
But she works out for free there.
Yeah.
And he's like,
you want to see this deck and balls.
Yeah.
He's old as fuck too by the way.
For him.
Yeah.
What's that?
Uh,
nothing.
Just checking.
Avails.
Coming in.
Okay.
So,
um,
so we uh,
went for breakfast this morning.
Yeah.
And which is nice cause we haven't seen each other in days.
I know days and my wanted to catch up with you when hear about Cincinnati and we
got our meals,
we had our breakfast and then you ate yours in about 30 seconds.
And then I ate mine at a normal human pace.
So I'm halfway through mine and you're done eating and you're like,
ah,
I gotta go to the bathroom,
which is what you do to me 90% of the time.
So half a plate of food.
And now I'm sitting at the fucking restaurant all alone,
eating my breakfast while you take a shit at the restaurant for 10 15 minutes
and you,
by the way,
you didn't tell me you had to shit.
He would just like,
I gotta go
as the bathroom.
All right.
Yeah.
That's what happened.
That's what happens.
What's wrong with that?
Because it takes the fun out of going to a restaurant and we were almost done.
No,
we weren't
almost halfway done with my meal.
We're more than halfway done.
I was nine.
I needed someone to sit there and talk to me.
No,
you were.
You were more than halfway done,
right?
What are you doing?
I'm doing something.
She says,
this is what I get asked every time
because we're doing a show.
It's for a reason.
Obviously it's for the show.
Okay.
Jesus.
What is it?
A Special Collin?
You can keep talking,
Babe.
Oh my God,
but you're the only person that I'm supposed to be talking.
I can still handle the conversation with you.
God,
I can still do this.
This is our marriage.
20 years from now,
I add white male.
I wasn't fucking gone that,
first of all,
I was gone two minutes and you make it a big deal.
It wasn't two minutes,
so it was like 15 no,
it wasn't
that.
If I wanted to have breakfast alone,
I would have gone alone.
But you didn't have breakfast alone.
Bring my breakfast alone.
It was not half of your breakfast.
It was,
you're such a liar.
You lie.
You lie for a living.
Oh my God.
This is a crazy amount of lies.
Seriously.
And then really?
Yeah.
What?
How?
How was your shit though?
You didn't even do it was awesome and it only took a few minutes.
That was back right away.
It wasn't,
it wasn't bs.
How was it on the trip?
It was not bad.
A little bit.
A little bit of mud,
little sludge,
but other than that,
it's fine.
What caused putting off the tests that he wanted me to do because I'm doing that
food allergy test.
See how that goes?
When's that happening?
Tomorrow.
Oh,
okay.
Good.
So we'll have some news for people next week.
Yeah.
Hopefully
pretty good.
I think I have a food allergy.
What are you allergic tail.
I don't know.
I'm too dumb to know,
but that's why I'm going.
Yeah.
All right.
We'll see.
I'm excited to find out.
Yeah,
you always lie.
And you always exaggerate about like how long I was gone and how crazy it is
that I was gone.
So ridiculous.
You're always like,
oh my God,
I had this whole meal alone.
I said half a mil.
Half the meal,
half of it.
What would you prefer?
I do in this situation,
I had to go,
but here's the thing with you is that you can hold in the dump for a long time.
We've been on road trips together where you're like,
I gotta dig a shit.
You have to know that if I decide I got to go is because I got to go see.
You've been holding it in already for like half hours.
He's saying,
cause you can't hold it a long time.
Yeah.
I have to go when I go.
That's the whole point.
I have to go.
You don't get it.
I gotta go.
Uh,
you got it.
You hit something.
Yeah.
What'd you do?
You ruined something.
I just hit this [inaudible] you always be ruined something.
What'd you ruin?
I hate you the most.
Ah,
fuck it Todd.
It's hot.
I need it to be less hot right now.
Okay.
Uh,
oh.
I know.
It's horrible.
I did,
I did new show again this week.
[inaudible] and sheer tenacity.
That was really fun.
Um,
this is like the difference between the good ones and the not so good ones I
figured out isn't me.
It's them.
It's when they're game for it.
And these people were like in such a good mood for this good.
I walk in,
I had diamond earrings in and they're like,
hey,
like they were just jazz for it,
you know?
Okay.
Let me see if you can,
oh,
you know what?
Even on their own,
they put this up on the,
uh,
the Kyron no,
they didn't own their own good that up on the Kyron.
Look at that.
I saw that on.
So Tom Segura and then quotations,
the water champion.
Uh Huh.
Did I,
what did they say when you told him to put that up?
Okay.
They're just like,
whatever.
Yeah.
That's so funny.
Wouldn't be a good idea.
I don't think so.
You talked about consuming a lot of h two o you want to talk about Water
Olympics?
Well the water championships,
I actually won,
I'm the current water champions southern California that have these
competitions.
I drank two and a half gallons,
six hours and I'm just very proud of it,
you know.
Oddly enough,
my wife also competed and she came in last place cause she dragged,
you ever seen a Yorkie drink water?
And they go like,
yeah,
I,
it was great.
That's so funny.
Cause that's why some guys,
I get it now because on Instagram I posted photos of me drinking water and this
and people were like,
those are a Yorkie sips.
And I was like,
oh that's so funny.
What a funny thing to say to me.
Well now I see the origin is a Yorkie.
SIBS.
Yep.
That's a really funny,
interesting.
Why don't you check your email?
I'm about to send you,
you saw boy,
what the fuck did he do now?
What if fuck,
fuck,
fuck who?
I don't know.
Let me see if I haven't.
Yada Yada,
combat.
What you're about to do.
Oh yeah,
I do.
Okay.
Oh,
here,
here.
You don't even know what I'm going to do.
What about this though?
This was also from the interview.
You got to watch
Mark Chrysler Chrysler plant.
So fat
really fat.
A
friend of mine and we're having like a who was fatter thing going on and he's,
he's like so much fatter.
So I tell them the,
the big news,
which is that I talked to bart and I know it's Bark Chrysler.
Oh boy.
I talked to Bart and now we are doing it.
This comes on sale today it's the bird is fat shirt.
Hashtag bird is fat.
We've um,
normally we wouldn't sell a shirt so close to the release of another shirt,
you know,
we spread it out,
but this is special.
This is really special.
We did lower the price because we wanted a people to get a little bit of a,
a price break on it,
but it's still super high quality.
It's a,
what is it called?
A water based ink.
Smooth feel.
Um,
and then you know,
it's really about picking teams.
It's like what I was saying to this to this lady,
um,
it's about picking the team because to be fair,
twilight TMA affair,
we,
we also made a Thomas fat shirt.
Barks been a good sport about it.
So we figured and I,
you know,
I get some of his,
I get his seven fans will message me sometimes and be like,
no,
you're a fat and then you 7,000 we'll hit him up.
But here's what it's about.
We're splitting the costs,
we're splitting everything in it.
It's really about which team are you on it,
his team,
Jacob and team.
If your team Tom get a bird is fat shirt.
If you're
inside you get a Tom as fat shirt.
They're going to be a ad on my site at [inaudible] dot com free shipping and the
in the domestic us and um,
where I'm just hoping to end the end to show him numbers wise who has more
support.
He's fatter,
much fatter.
He thinks he can rally his troops.
There's like 10 trips.
Like yeah,
there's no troops.
I know.
So he doesn't have mommy power behind him.
Yeah,
he was like,
whatever.
Over normal pod coast.
Yeah,
you do.
It's fun.
Some stupid
fucking better than me.
His fans,
right.
The dumb.
His tweets to our fans,
super creative.
Like they're like comedy writers and his fans were like,
fuck you man.
And you're like,
oh good one.
Not Too smart.
No know.
Our listeners are smart.
Well his listeners are,
have his same fucking like mentality.
It's not,
it's kind of pretty baseline stuff,
you know,
again,
ah,
I predict,
uh,
the bird is fast shirts will be sold her the rate we're going to sell like two
Thomas Fats.
I want it to like,
absolutely.
I want the numbers to just,
I want it to be a landslide.
Like a massacre.
Of course.
Like I want to start with like,
dude,
you know,
I actually,
you know what,
there was actually substantial Thomas fat shirt,
so you know,
it was like,
like 65 or something.
He's like,
see,
we told you,
Ooh,
we sold 800 bird is fat shirts and then I hope people start wearing a bird is
fat shirts to Burt shows.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
The best thing,
but him to look out and see a sea of burden shirts as he's performing shirtless
in clubs
because he does his whole set shirtless and then he'll looks at like Subarus for
anyways.
Okay.
It's very exciting.
It is very exciting.
I'm very hunched.
Check your email.
Okay.
Let's see.
What did you send me?
Ah,
okay.
For Christina,
this says,
I'm sorry.
It's interesting.
We've compiled some images over the years here.
Uh,
you may want to look at the overwhelming evidence.
Now.
What the fuck is this blue band here was kind enough to compile these evidence,
more evidence against you being the water champion,
number one.
You'll notice that as a full bottle of water.
So this is still have your special completely normal on Frick's.
And if you'll look at the bottom,
the time code here,
it's the very end of your special and you've got a completely full bottle of
water onstage with you.
It's like rob water.
I can't tell him which one is,
it looks full to me actually.
I don't know how anybody could be able to,
I can see it just fine the way though.
The light hits it.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Blue Bam.
Yana mass submit.
Yeah.
Consideration.
Okay.
That,
that is one full bottle of water.
So you just have it there so people think you hydrate.
Okay.
It's prop water like it always is with you all show no drinking.
You never drink it.
You never take one sip and that's special.
Okay,
let's look at the other evidence.
Your honor,
please.
Okay,
one second.
One second.
Let me get this real quick.
It's really dark image.
No,
let me see.
Does this play about Bark Chrysler?
Okay.
Sorry.
Just making sure that was here.
Um,
can we please
Chrysler?
Sorry.
Part Chrysler.
He's so fat.
Okay.
All right.
Uh,
now this is your next bit of evidence here.
Yes.
Okay.
Here we go.
Hmm.
That's curious how you're messing this up.
Okay.
And this is your other mostly stories and if you'll notice where at the very end
of the special here and the time code,
it's at the end,
you can see and there is yet another full water bottle and that's at the very
end.
Look,
you took a leg maybe like,
like you would say a Yorkie sip and then the rest of it's totally full and we're
at the end of the special.
Okay,
so again,
more stunt water,
all talk,
no hydration.
If you ask anybody listening now,
that was at the Saturday late show,
let's say,
okay,
let's ask them how the,
how the set ended because I'll tell you what happened.
I did a show at the end when the show was over,
a pounded a bottle of water for everybody and they celebrate.
You didn't do that on mostly stories
I did off camera.
Didn't make never hydrate off camera.
We all know this.
Okay,
next piece of evidence please.
Yana.
I was at the comedy store the Saturday and I hydrated while I was on stage.
Mommy's were in the audience.
Again,
allow this evidence here you have a full glass of this is you on stage this and
Austin Sacramento and you've got a full glass,
a pint glass of water with a little slice of lemon.
Also at the end of the set we had this listener submit this as evidence that you
didn't touch that water the whole time anyways,
a lot of water,
no drinking,
and there we go.
All this.
This one's the most compelling beginning of the set.
How would you know that?
How is she doing?
What is she doing?
She's in disbelief.
This is
for me in Irvine,
in sperm vine and Tom is closing out his set.
Know a pint glass of water and the interpretor because interpretor there,
she's eyeballing the water.
You've drawn a line from her to make it look like she's looking at the water,
but like,
wow,
I've never seen that much water.
Exactly.
That's so stupid.
Exactly like how long this man's been talking without taking a lot of doing the
shit.
Nobody believe.
That's so ridiculous.
That's ridiculous.
And it's not accurate.
Nothing that you do.
And also there've been reports.
My reports indicate that while on the road performing to you hydrate with club
soda with Soda Water,
which isn't the same as water because our sodium and actually dehydrates you.
Oh my sources say that you drank soda water.
Never.
You can ask anybody.
Hey,
where you at?
The Liberty Township shows
this weekend people will see me drinking bottles of water.
People were like,
you're the fucking water champ.
People were yelling at outman.
Okay.
Yeah.
I know what I've been having,
and I'm sorry to admit this guy's number ones and number twos the last couple of
days,
just not,
I haven't been eating well.
I've been taking a lot of like these new vitamins.
I think it's the vitamin,
the Biedermann's.
Yeah,
and water.
I haven't been drinking as much water.
You Go,
you got,
you got it.
Soften
that stool of Yana.
That's episode two 74 your mom's house and 20 minute mark.
Defendant admits she does not consume the eggs too,
that she claimed to this.
Now,
first of all,
I was this close,
isolated again incident.
It sounded as if I was sick.
Something was going on.
If we could contextualize that properly,
that would be great.
You know the other thing we can conduct lives.
We have a new logo for the tracks.
You realize here's the new word over the show.
New logo for your mom's house.
Here it is.
You're looking at it.
That's the logo.
It's me bed and it just says Tom,
the water champion and that's to your mom's house.
Looks dumb.
There you go.
You look good with those damn earrings.
Actually,
I know.
I got it.
If a good on the last patriarch did,
nobody said I thought they were going to be like,
ha ha.
And they're all like,
well,
that outfit is like it.
Actually.
It's just part of that outfit,
right?
There's a black shirt with gold lion on it.
That hat,
those sunglasses.
Nobody even gives me shit about wearing sunglasses at these things.
I thought this one would be like,
are you serious?
He's such an asshole.
No,
I think thought it.
I was like,
what a jerk.
Of course that isn't asshole move.
I'm not supposed to do that.
But I think at these shows when you walk in like this,
they think that's your real,
that's the real deal.
He's a comedian so you get away with it.
But I don't think they think I'm being funny.
You know what I mean?
I think they like,
oh that's how that guy,
where's your water right now?
I'm third year saying,
please,
I'm thirsty.
What's the next least?
Come on.
I have it.
Give me the fucking water.
Why don't you have,
cause I asked you to bring it and you wouldn't fucking bring it.
You know what I have for you?
What?
Cause I love you.
I have backup.
Look was in the tiny fridge under the desk.
Backup.
Hydration's.
Why?
Because I'm the real water champions.
Really Shit about hydrating.
Is it cold?
Thank you.
What flavor?
That's a Kedwin.
Yeah.
It's been a long time since I've had a great fruit.
Look,
it's not like Croix,
is it?
When is it Lacroix L'aquila they claim it's Lacroix.
I don't think so.
But then Saint Croix,
right?
That place Saint Croix.
It's the same
pump pump.
Lynn Moose.
Now
how that's going to start and that's why we stopped drinking these on this show
because,
oh,
that's right.
We're really adequate.
It's so blue bay.
I was like,
um,
you guys were burping a lot on these.
Look,
look,
watch episodes.
So we cut it out.
Shit.
You're right.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
It's hot.
Can we lower their well,
is baby jeans still sleeping?
I don't know.
He can handle it.
Bed.
Okay.
What's
going on?
All right.
Yeah,
so blue man.
Just remind me to remind people that I'm ordered double pipe,
classic shirts that haven't gotten them,
that they're all coming out this week.
Oh,
that's such a good shirt.
The reorders.
I've been wearing mine.
It's very soft.
It fits nicely is,
and you're sharing something really cool with the world.
You know you've been on this kick by the way,
where you're like,
you want to hear really cool fart.
I got you.
Good yesterday too.
I go,
you want to hear it cool?
Far and you go,
nope.
And I farted real big back.
Remember I sat on your lap and I farted.
You also fostered in your middle of your sleep last night?
Yeah.
And it was like you don't remember that it was like a three parter from my mom
and you went,
you don't remember that and then you reached over and you like tap me and I'm
like fame.
You're like pointing it out in your sleep.
Yes.
Wow.
I feel like I'm the FARC champ then.
Yeah.
It was really,
really nice to be like dead asleep.
[inaudible] you
and your sleep.
Oh my.
Um,
oh my gosh.
There's a lot to go over.
There's a,
what do you want first foray into my sleep.
I'm so proud of.
I'm proud of myself.
You want to talk about uh,
gender pronouns or whatever.
We haven't visited that world in a minute.
I'm curious to know how are you feeling today?
What Pronoun Are you going by?
You said that was so much surface level contempt.
You're like,
how are you feeling today?
What Pronoun Do you feel like?
Yeah,
I'm serious.
What Pronoun Are we going by?
What are you doing?
I am a lead gender.
What's that?
How the gender,
Allie,
what does that is new?
I uh,
it's like when you incorporate like,
it's like your Arabic,
but you're a,
you're like a donkey,
but you're also like a sexless.
I know what you're talking about.
Arabic tellable
you're Arab.
Sorry.
Arab gendered.
Okay.
Hey everybody,
welcome back this week and we'll be talking to you about sweet on nouns and
pronouns.
Preferred gender pronouns or PGPS,
um,
PG,
whatever you call him.
Pronounce the things we used to refer to people in the third person that aren't
their names.
They're also often used as the linguistic representation that people's gender
identities.
So you're really important.
Really,
really,
what's his pronoun?
Well,
I'll wait and he said,
shoot,
I,
I didn't want,
I didn't mean to,
you might have,
I mean,
Z day.
Yeah,
you can go.
They them.
Yeah.
Um,
fuck.
Yeah.
The first and most important rule regarding pronouns is to respect people's
pronouns.
That's a big thing.
Holly's,
there should be no question.
There are no exceptions.
If someone says,
this is the Pronoun I want you to use to refer to me,
that is the Pronoun you will use her for.
To them period.
To do otherwise is offensive and invalidating and humiliating and at best
awkward.
I agree with that.
That's,
I mean,
that's an,
that's an honest statement right there.
Once somebody says,
call me.
Like if you're like,
hey guys,
I'm not a she,
I'm a Zit.
Zared deserve them.
Zam They Zurbaran
[inaudible] he's saying,
I'm not a Zuckerberg.
You're offending me right now.
Oh,
you have to identify me in the way in which I chose,
I've chosen to be identity to what you're saying.
Yeah.
I use in,
I'd actually had never heard Zuckerberg.
I'm as overt gendered.
Okay.
It's from,
it's a pre rape Cosby era.
Crazy.
Herbert's you ever heard of dessert?
I'm the guys we show
[inaudible] [inaudible] put it in pop up in your pussy.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah,
I remember.
Um,
okay.
So far I'm on board.
I'm a rule number two.
Always ask,
don't assume it's far better to ask me someone's Pronoun is just be like,
hey,
hi.
How are you?
What's your name?
What's Your Pronoun?
Okay.
I don't know that part.
Let's be honest.
That's a little more than awkward to be like,
yeah,
what's up?
What's Your Pronoun?
No,
no,
no.
I mean,
uh,
he's trying to make it seem like that's not a big deal to do that.
Yeah,
I understand the idea of like we should all,
you should find out the person's Pronoun,
but it is kind of a weird question.
Like it is kind of hard to be like,
hi.
Hi.
Nice meeting you.
What's your,
what's your pronoun?
Yeah.
It's like say,
Hey,
what's up?
What's going on?
Can I see your tits real quick?
Right.
Look,
that's how you test your balls.
Are they small balls?
Yeah.
Do you like when you do we like Cox and hangalow balls or by your hand below
cogs?
Yeah,
I guess,
but I maybe,
you know,
I don't know.
He's saying it's not a big deal.
I think it's a big deal.
Yeah.
Cause I'm a person,
I've interacted with people and I know that it's a big deal
to be like,
Hey,
what's your name?
What's that?
What's your pronouns?
That girl at the comedy store.
I thought it was non-binary.
I wanted her to come in and I was like,
oh,
you're non-binary.
Right?
And she looked at me like,
go fuck yourself for me to ask essentially what's your pronoun?
She kind of gave me an a go fuck yourself.
She didn't,
she didn't say it,
but her eyes were like,
wait,
what?
She's like,
oh no,
I'm not nine bear binary.
My friend's daughter is or whatever,
and I'm like,
Oh,
did she?
She didn't like the Pronoun question that she look nonbinary.
Yeah,
yeah.
She's definitely other gender identified,
but I don't know.
You know what a Pronoun is?
I don't know.
See,
I feel like it's offensive to ask her.
It feels this guys thing of like she used to always ask is not,
especially as a cisgendered person,
I feel as though my cisgendered privilege.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I feel like I'm being a deck.
Hey,
what's up?
What's Your Pronoun?
Don't assume it's far better to ask for someone's Pronoun is just be like,
Hey,
I think he has burns.
What's your name?
What's Your Pronoun?
Not have a dealer.
Hey,
just want her to confirm what's,
what'd you pronto?
Isn't he?
He's nice bird away.
What gender is the bird?
Is it rude to ask Bluebell?
What gender is that?
Bird.
Chirps.
I do think that's a lot to ask,
man.
I want to put the burden,
the other room,
gender identity and how they present themselves.
You care about their pronouns.
You'd ask that someone's name.
You should ask about the Pronoun to.
All right.
Yeah,
that seems like a lot to do.
I think someone should bring it up.
That's what I mean.
Yes.
I think.
I think that what you need to ask of somebody who has respect people's pronouns,
but to be like start going around asking people,
how about you volunteers?
Especially like if you know people are going to assume that you're one or the
other because then now you're going to be more offended when someone calls you a
he and you're not.
Not a lot to ask.
Yeah.
If you were to walk in and be like,
I'm,
hi,
my name is Christina,
please refer to me as bay.
Yeah.
Otherwise,
why would anybody assumed that you're not going to let you know what I mean?
Then you can't get all offended at people.
Maybe he's not.
Maybe he's saying to ask when you think somebody's on the,
you know yeah.
On the gender line,
the non,
the non binary.
Yeah.
Maybe I didn't hear that in the clip but maybe that's what he's implying.
I don't know.
I don't see that.
Most people are really like when someone asks of them cause it can feel very
welcome birds.
Shane leaves really coming out.
You got to watch the audio guy
and you're like,
okay cool.
He's sweet.
He's the way he's saying that he's,
he no,
he's saying if you asked somebody in there he that you know,
oh you're going to be like,
oh Duh.
I mean coming out.
Worst case I want
to be like,
uh,
my pronouns.
He does.
And you're like,
okay,
well cool memories and it's not a big deal at all.
Oh I see.
I think it's a big deal still.
I think minimizing,
asking them what have you really offend somebody by asking them,
listen,
the world is too complicated for me now with all these new,
uh,
genders,
I don't know what to do.
Yeah.
I think,
I think you can really guide the guide is it's making it more complicated.
I don't know.
Yeah,
there are a lot of pronouns out.
They're like,
no,
I want more slowly and slowly adding more.
So the two most common allergen he has is traditionally considered a male
pronouns.
She initially considered eight female pronouns.
However,
it's important to note that some people use he or she but did not identify as
male or female.
Now you're really fucking people up.
So now he,
not only do you have to say like,
all right,
whatever gender you are is fine.
I might like,
he don't fucking think that makes me a male gender.
Fuck him on.
So now we have to ask,
what do you prefer?
And then what really are you under that?
Oh,
that's so much work.
Yeah.
Just an Lti common ones are he and she,
she has is traditionally considered a male pronoun and she is true initially
considered female pronouns.
Awesome.
However,
it's important to note that some people use he or she but did not identify as
male or female.
So
they're assholes.
Just so you know,
they should identify,
someone says,
Oh,
don't make life easy for everybody.
Just identify words,
fucking Pronoun.
Of course
you can't just assume that they're male or you know,
if they say she can't see.
Um,
so if you were to say like I prefer,
I prefer like masculine pronouns are male pronouns.
It's sort of implying that everyone else who uses he
uses,
you know,
it is male or that like everyone else who identify as male uses heat,
which is not also not necessarily the case.
So it's better to just say I prefer he'd be done with it.
Any new people ever.
Because
in 2016 it is a complicated thing to meet a new person.
How about no,
no new anyone.
I'm going to start saying I like he him as my preferred Pronoun,
but I'm not necessarily mail to people when they meet me.
I wish she could explain this to your dad.
That's a great one to bring it out.
Let's do that.
Actually let's play the clip for him.
What?
That's what we're going to hear a lot.
Play that for your dad and we understand what he is.
Okay.
This is real new stuff to me buddy.
Yeah,
no.
So then they're also gender neutral pronouns.
Gender neutral pronouns can be used for anybody of any gender and they have no
gendered meanings attached to them at all,
which is cool.
Um,
and there are so many of them it was commonly used is they,
they is traditionally plural,
but we already used in the singular form to like maintain people's anonymity
here.
Like if you just don't know what their gender is,
you'll be like,
oh,
I was talking to a student and they told me Blah,
blah,
blah.
Totally normal.
So you can use it for specific people as well.
And a lot of people prefer they,
okay.
That's all that's on my Twitter bio.
Right.
You're the one of those people that prefer they now.
How's that working out for you?
Are People Respecting your pronoun mostly?
Well,
I think you really should.
It be really funny if you insisted that like your agent,
your manager call you babe,
do you think they would respect that
you think they would?
How do you institute this with,
when next thing is common?
I,
hold on,
Z can be spelled a bunch of different ways.
Why?
This is what I'm saying.
Like,
okay,
I get this in theory and I understand it as a theory.
How do you institute a new Pronoun Policy in your personal life?
Videos like this,
keep putting videos out guys.
It'sZ ,
Vermont to your employer,
Dakota,
who was like,
oh my God,
there's a not a preference is a requirement.
Yeah.
He went to della Mae explaining it to your family,
your friends,
your Twitter.
While it's,
it's overwhelming.
I think there's also this
total
bullshit,
uh,
pushback on an anybody again who questions or,
or it makes jokes about any of this.
They're like,
you don't fucking get the LGBT community.
You know,
like they,
well actually I've been talking to LGBT community people,
it's Lgbtq now
and a lot of the people I've talked to don't,
I don't,
it's different.
Like they think that this stuff is kinda out there.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
They're not really on board.
Right.
Because like,
like when I feel shit,
I'm like gay.
That's different than sexual orientation.
Yes.
So that's not the same you guys.
We gotta be respectful.
You know,
Jesus Christ,
too many things.
Too many things.
My Dad,
I feel like I'm on the fucking whole world we live in now.
It's like declension lake.
So like he,
him,
his and then Z fucking headache already from here.
Zee.
Zee like German are,
yeah,
there are a lot.
Throw a lot of options.
Senses.
I prefer Z.
Ask them what spelling,
if they can use it in a sentence.
No I'm not.
And that shows how much you care that you want to get their pronouns.
Right.
So that's,
that's a good one.
If you don't want to get them right cause you're too tired to get your pronouns.
I'd also seen air like,
like they but without the t h I've also seen dawn come combination of that.
Fuck that one.
Yes or huge or for human or commerce per person or Hurley or really or yo
or ah,
there's so many options.
It's so fascinating.
That's the word I choose.
A burden
to put on other people.
It's exhausting.
Station is pronouns.
Ask about on if you're not sure.
Always a good idea.
There's so much more to talk about with pronouns that I just don't want to talk
forever.
No,
we feel the same way.
So he's sweet.
He's a sweet guy,
but really cute kid.
Shit man.
After that,
I'm sorry I was disrespectful and I didn't ask his personality.
I don't even know their partner after that.
I feel like we could probably get into something like this.
It feels better.
Cleanse the palate.
Somebody that claims to have the longest part.
Recording,
recording,
recording.
A lot of people have seen this video and feel like,
you know,
manipulate it.
We'll also play this for my mother.
What do you think she'll say in this one?
There's a video.
Great.
But the visuals better.
Yeah.
This is when you got to get on the youtube to see guys.
We should tell her.
This is Brian.
Should I believe it?
[inaudible]
I know there's room tone here.
At least he knows how to edit cause there's some room tone.
Sounds authentic.
We're 40 seconds into this fucking car right now.
And then when he breathes,
it changes the tone of the fire.
Really?
Wow.
That is interesting.
But there's fluctuations and
[inaudible] right
now.
How come he's hiding his face?
I'd be proud if
he doesn't feel like you.
You know why he's not a Cincinnati fighter like me?
Ooh.
Do you realize we are just over a month away from now?
It's a big deal,
by the way,
this weekend.
And a lot of people were asking and you know,
I had press schedule,
I had to see family.
I wasn't able to go down there,
but the Lou ban went and visited the,
uh,
was it,
what do you call her?
Yeah,
zero.
Um,
you went to the renaissance?
Yeah.
How was it?
It was,
it was better than I expected.
Wow.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean,
you were able to like do some stuff that we'll see a little bit later.
Yeah.
Like I want to go into details,
but I also don't want to give away the surprise.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah,
we'll have wow.
But then have some stuff to show at some point.
Yeah.
Amazing stuff ahead.
Wow.
I can't wait.
What a claim.
Yeah.
Well,
this guy is far,
it's pretty impressive.
He's at a minute and five I can see as the final.
Yeah.
What do you think your tally was?
I,
you know,
I'll be honest,
I,
I'm going to give it
realistically.
Yeah,
20 seconds.
Yeah.
Do you feel that's an accurate representation?
That's a long farm and it was long,
but that's why it's the Cincinnati Fart.
It's not your every day for it.
It's a fart that goes down in history.
Yeah.
It's a fort.
You tell your children's Children's children,
and I'll tell you something,
people know more than you might imagine about it.
Really?
Yes.
What does that mean?
Very cryptic.
It's not as big a mystery.
It's not as hidden as you think.
It's not just on the show,
really.
It's people in Cincinnati now.
You mean the word?
Uh,
the smell is spread,
if you will.
Locals know best.
Wow.
That's what I'll say.
Yeah.
Well,
I'm,
I'm curious to hear this audio and I look forward to it and you'll believe blue
man.
It'll happen.
Wow.
This is still going the minute,
minute.
A long time.
Wow.
Oh,
you gave a little magic man at the end.
What it even smells like in that room right now.
I honestly,
I think those,
those kinds of,
the sound,
it doesn't have the same smell.
It's got a lot of sound.
Then there's not a lot of heat and not a lot of the smell,
but sometimes there's real powerful short ones,
not minute long.
That smell.
That was all for show.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That guy is impressive,
right?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
That's good work.
Yeah.
This.
One of the things I was excited about when I saw this clip come in.
Let me see if I know know I had a fart when you were gone.
I had an Amy's frozen dinner,
which was a big mistake,
and then I had some ranch flavored Kale chips on top of it.
Bad idea,
bad idea.
I laid in bed and I farted and it was like he ever fart and the smell is so
foreign to you.
You're like,
dude,
I've never even made a smell like that before.
Yeah,
that's what it felt like.
He was like someone else's Fart.
It wasn't even mine.
Those are really a trip where there were times when you travel,
you have those where you take your shit and you're like,
if somebody's shooting between my legs right here right now,
is someone else farting
in bed with me because this part doesn't smell like my own brand.
Yeah,
those are those really kind of scare you a little bit.
To me,
they do like when it upsets you
because you're not supposed to be upset by your own.
That's the whole point of the joy of foreign.
You know that it doesn't upset you.
There's a reason for that is not just because it's not that that it's yours,
it's that your brain alerts you that this isn't going to smell good.
And when you're,
when that happens,
the way you processed the smell.
Yeah,
it's different.
Versus like if you walk as a surprise one,
interesting because your brain tells you there's going to smell bad.
It's a reward when it comes true.
You're validating.
You're like,
oh yeah,
it doesn't smell so interesting.
So the,
it smells the writer.
You are like,
the more correct your brain is and that's why he get a high.
Wow.
What a neat science scientific episode for our listeners.
Pretty neat.
Pretty neat man.
Always trying to teach this stuff on this show.
Stories about education.
Um,
do you want to hear this one?
I thought you would really enjoy,
we've actually seen this guy before,
but never on,
never this clip.
Oh,
everyone is wired their own way.
I'm a,
some people are wired towards blondes.
It's a big women's skinny women,
various authenticity
ethnicities.
I'm not sure that's the words or
z.
It's not dessert.
Nativities Burt's
wire.
So authenticity is,
I'm wired towards older women
babyface.
Kyle Jones has never dated a woman.
He's own h prefabbing relationships with
mouth open mouth.
God,
this lady,
how will you think she is?
But she's really old.
She looks like she's 90 she looks at her mouth is fully open.
His tongue.
Oh,
that is kind of like a lizard tongue.
It looks like he's trying to save her life right now.
It looks like CPR.
Staci
romances grandma's in the seventies eighties and even nineties
oof,
Bro.
I mean I'm all about everybody getting some,
but that's
not 90 on.
Yeah,
it makes us decker.
I bet.
I know his dicta hangs below his balls or his balls at Henkel though.
His Dick
when I first met cow.
Quite thrilled.
It's very flattering devs
and he was a very nice,
I sometimes I feel like he's,
that's not helping the bed.
I,
yeah,
that's kind of not the right analogy.
Or He's like my son that I fuck.
It's kind of grows trying to think what it would take for me to fuck this woman.
All right,
let's talk about it.
Let's do it.
What would it take time could it take?
That's what I'm saying.
Take the real,
how do you get it up?
Well,
I'd have to have a mask on so I can't see her.
Like I have to,
you have to put other visuals in front of me.
You'd wear the mask or you put a mask on her?
No,
I would put a virtual reality mask on me so I could see something else.
Totally cheating.
And that negates the whole project and do it.
I mean,
she's got a smell like diarrhea.
She's probably,
she smells,
you know,
old and Shitty.
They all smell.
Then she looks like she smokes,
so I don't know.
Well,
she used to smoke her teeth look good for 91.
Yeah.
They don't look that bad,
but she also looks like a guy.
Right.
You know,
like if you just go like,
Hey,
what do you see there?
I know you're saying like a nice old man.
Like uh,
yeah,
like Dolph Lundgren.
A little what?
Oh,
just thinking of it like a guy at a sandwich shop.
You know who's like,
you want,
you want mustard on that?
What do you want?
It looks like to me it would be really,
really something to just say like,
Hey,
just go perform.
I think if you were just like,
don't,
if you,
if you would go abstain for a month,
so you're just reel back now juiced up and then,
and then you just have her like you go,
I'll just close my eyes and hey,
but her,
her Bologna doesn't feel the same.
Oh my God.
It's all loose.
Can you,
what do you think her meow is like at that age?
Oh my God.
Being serious.
What happens to the fucking desert on the planet?
It's so bad and hanging.
It's not good.
Nothing's good.
Do you think they have pubes to old people have fallout?
Yeah,
but there's only a few left,
so she's probably like,
do like the bald post,
but
it's a lot.
She's really,
she's 90 so gnarly dude.
I mean I want to like bring her a cup of tea or something,
but just so frail too.
It's,
it's not even safe for her,
isn't,
it?
Doesn't feel like it went,
Dude.
Whoa.
He's unusual.
Tasting women is too extreme.
Kyle takes a different view.
People to think of their parents or grandparents having sex for the other.
They just don't do that.
Yes,
they do.
One,
some of them have throw up.
Yeah.
Well I'm glad he exists these days.
Getting out of it.
He was someone that Dick around a lot of old ladies,
which I guess is nice.
Well,
she's actually really put together for a 91 91 she walks hunched over,
she looks like she's
getting all this young,
young d.
There you go.
What do you mean there you go and you get nice and old bounce on one of these
young days.
He got
it
from a young age.
Kyle realized the pinups,
which were exciting.
His friends won't catch in his eye.
Well,
the first time I realized all of a sudden the older woman probably was 12 or 13
years old.
Really?
What's funny,
the things that they're self conscious about is what I'm into.
I like lions.
I like the neck feature.
You know,
women worry about their boobs saggy.
I think the natural hang looks great fan of platinum.
Erin.
Oh,
I can say gray.
I guess I'm platinum on the fan.
I'm glad I'm here.
Got To keep this guy's number.
No.
How do I get it?
What's his last name?
All right.
Just in case.
Should,
yeah,
you get die before me.
Husbands always do.
I got a call up fucking Kyle or whatever his name.
She'll be old by then.
You've got to find a new Kyle.
That's the beauty of the Internet,
man.
Yeah.
There's always some lunatic out there.
Then wants to bang a 90 year old,
old,
old fucking my regular I suppose up there.
Yeah.
My bald regularly slobbery ready when back when he doesn't talk like,
no,
not doing an impression of you all
take your teeth out.
You came in where I worked or buy something that I know my phone number gave me
his and then every day you dropped me on the phone until we finally went out.
It makes you feel wonderful dating somebody younger than you.
Yeah,
I'm sure it does.
It makes you feel alive again.
It's hard to watch as a kid.
The hard part's wonderful.
Oh,
I am a south.
Hey.
Amazes me and I like it.
Oh God,
the kissing was the hardest thing to watch with these ads.
I just can't imagine that picture.
How much she smells.
I know.
No,
like the mouth.
It's an old mouse.
Yeah.
It's one of those.
Or they like ha ha ha.
And you feel that hot air leaving smell really bad.
What does her box smelling do?
Imagine I buy arms to settle down.
Kyle isn't monogamous and enjoy stating several women at the same time.
Yeah.
God bless your soul.
He meant 68 year old.
Great Grandmother.
Great.
Two years ago on a dating website.
First contacted me.
I did question is a nice tick tattoo was twice
when we had dinner.
I liked him.
I felt at ease with them.
So she's uh,
I started seeing them trailer
trash for sure.
Oh yeah.
That's a tattoo.
Yeah.
It doesn't look good when you're 71 savage woman.
He's a savage too.
No,
she is.
She is.
No,
he's the savage.
She is.
She's a great grandmother.
She's 68.
She needs love too.
Yeah,
she's,
she's a fucking psycho.
He's the cycle.
Keller people sometimes that are hard core.
What I do for me in the the on the ball chart on your after money here after a
heritage.
I hear that all the time.
It's not sure what all,
um,
I do this because I like it and they like it too.
He's got no Vogel,
blah,
Blah.
I'll add up.
It's a,
it's tough to understand.
Yeah.
It's tough and I mean,
this chick,
Jesus,
it's tough.
These moms,
Cecelia fairly supports his romantic choices that would mix.
It took some getting used to,
yeah.
First Time Kylie brought home a girlfriend,
they your mother's 22 she's much better looking,
be
a young woman back then.
I still feel like,
oh,
she was like,
wait,
play poking at me,
bitch.
Well,
here's the good news.
At least her son is not going to knock up some girl and ruin his life.
Right.
That's true.
That's the big plus there.
Yeah.
What?
What can go wrong?
You know?
Actually this is a win win for him.
These broads do die.
Leave him money.
It's great.
He's doing a great service for them.
Sure.
Who's it hurting?
Just on us to watch it.
They could probably die while they're doing it.
That's probably,
yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
He's probably going to witness a lot of death.
Yeah.
Or have like a lot of imagine it.
A lot of people you dated died in a certain,
oh,
isn't that sad?
Well,
yeah.
I'm saying like for him it can be like,
Hey,
I'm remember last decade when those 30 girls you dated died
and someone was like,
wait,
what?
And he's like,
oh,
I did.
Oh yeah.
Really old people.
But still,
they all die within a few years even I it,
yeah.
I saw a documentary about old people in a retirement community and they talk
about how sometimes they don't even want to make new friends because they're
going to die.
You're gonna die or why?
Why bother with it?
Uh,
relationships,
a great outlook on life.
I agree.
My whole thing about leading people and I agree and stop loving people.
You know,
it's so funny.
It's like,
I think about when you're going to die.
Yeah.
And I was just saying about that last night,
how was like,
you know,
I don't really,
if he dies,
I'm not going to try to like go out and find another day.
Like fuck it.
Like cares,
who cares if I'm old and wrinkly and fucking fat,
you know?
Serious.
Yeah.
What am I going to do?
Find another husband and do all this.
It got old.
No Way.
Why I just fine now I just be alone.
I mean it's a nice,
it's a fantasy.
Obviously I lose myself in like three hours.
Yeah.
Like a lot of times I'm like,
Oh,
you found the stares of what happens next week.
You know,
that kind of thing where I'd be like,
Oh,
you know,
you do the funeral and it's like,
and you're laughing the whole time you're on Tinder.
At the funeral I always pictured too,
like,
you know,
like the day you die,
just cleaning out your closet,
like throwing everything out.
Like right.
I got all this room now hanging up new shirts and then,
yeah.
And then,
you
know,
showing the place to people like,
Hey,
look all this space,
I got to hours to a new wife.
Yeah.
Well you get a new wife to replace me.
Well,
I think you date right away.
I think they always say like strike while the irons hot.
So like I'll be like,
Ooh,
I'm needy.
You know?
I think that's enticing.
Broken bird.
Yeah.
The broken wing.
Someone's going to want to rescue.
Yup.
Okay.
So I dunno.
I think,
I think basically dirt goes on the casket and you go,
I'm single.
Yeah.
That kind of thing.
Good for you.
How's that working for you?
I will see.
How's it working?
It's not gonna work for you when make haunt your house and your dreams.
You're fighting on fucking with you.
I'm like,
Hey Tom,
this is fucking bitch in my bed.
I could see doing that.
Yeah,
of course.
I will keep her away from my kid asshole.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
I've asked Kelly why he prefers older women and you tell me because the older
women are there,
they're more mature and now there's somebody who can actually sit down and talk
to,
that's what he likes.
He's not hurting your body.
I don't think that it's really anybody's business.
Well let me ask you,
what do you think he has in common with a 91 year old?
He is,
well how old is Kyle here?
30 maybe something like that.
She was born in 1900 and this guy wants to have,
you know what I'm saying?
She's born in 1912 then.
Okay.
I cause I don't do it
to man.
When is she born?
She's 91.
Let's see,
28 she was born in 1927.
Jesus Christ.
So in 1927 they didn't have to,
they even have cars back then.
Yeah,
the model t she drove a model t around,
didn't even have penicillin or soap.
She's seen the whole world.
That's what I'm saying.
There's bitches,
they have nothing in common.
Their worlds are so different and she sees lightening cause I want to turn the
lights on that.
Yeah,
totally different worlds.
He's just sitting there eating that old fucking ass and box.
Can we,
let's go onto the next topic.
He can't do this anymore.
It's too depressing the making out.
It's too much to watch.
Watch 1927 man,
we got a female.
Somebody wrote in about the cookie thief last interesting.
And because I still have not cracked the case well here,
this might help you.
So as I think the bigger issue of the cookie thief saga is that Christina was
hiding to cookies in her purse with absolutely no intention of sharing either
one of them with her family wrapping
a selfish asshole.
Wow.
Bravo.
Oh Wow.
First of all,
American.
you do,
you have a good point.
I had just gotten those cookies as a gift from uncle Dave the night before.
I didn't even have a chance.
We got home late that night.
We put baby jeans to bed and we collapsed into bed.
And the next morning that that was eight in the morning that I notice a cookie
thief has truck.
So there was no time to even share.
So the cookie thief got in there.
I don't even know how he knew or she knew I had cookies in there.
How,
how did the cookie thief know that they were even in there?
I don't know.
I was always over here.
Thank you.
Snuck in his real name to ban,
uh,
time for the cookie thief or whatever.
I don't know.
But again,
it's a real interesting,
interesting.
And I ate the other one.
It was really good.
Let me see.
It was a wedding cookie from Cincinnati.
Some special company,
right?
It's like a special cookie was,
yeah.
Yeah.
Really good.
Here's another bit of Fan Mail.
Hey,
Mommy's asked my wife to the day if she wanted to hear a really funny fart and
she said,
no,
nope.
That happened.
She said,
how did you know it was going to be funny?
And I said,
all farts are funny.
We laughed and laughed.
Thanks for the podcast,
Arnie.
It's a family show.
Oh yeah.
I got my double pipe classic in the mail yesterday and love it.
You are not lying.
It's very soft and comfy.
Wore it today.
Nobody knew what it meant but I did.
That's the thing was I was asking people at shows and Cincy that wore them.
I go is anybody asking you what that is?
Cause I want to hear stories of someone being like,
hey what is that?
And someone being like,
you know when you
fart and Burp at the same time.
I want to hear those.
Sounds like a really good commercial for it.
Yeah man.
What is a double pipe classic?
Well funny you should ask even a bourbon farther the same time
somebody,
oh listen to this.
The poop bag pillowcase story that was told in the last episode was also
represent,
was also referenced in Episode 19 Oh my goodness.
The validity of hearing the same Brown story twice helps me trust Tommy's poop
pile story.
It makes me sad that the runner up to the water champion doesn't believe her
main.
Oh my God.
First of all,
I need to start going through the ANA.
Thank you Hannah.
Because somebody is selecting them kind of a biased way.
It's interesting how the bias is towards everything that's coming in.
I'm just passing along.
Sure,
sure.
And he's just selecting the ones to read.
Interesting.
These are in there and Tra blue Bam.
Put them in there.
Now,
just because one story is accurate,
the pillowcase doesn't mean the poo pile is accurate.
Poop piles accurate?
It is not.
You've changed the details.
I haven't since the last time.
When your advisor,
you're the liar.
You keep calling me a liar.
You're liar.
What did,
I came home yesterday and you've got these two on your thumbs.
Okay.
And I go,
what happened to your thumbs?
Yeah,
I go,
what happened to your thens?
You Go,
oh yeah,
one night.
Some eye,
some guide.
Dare me to jump over a parking meter and I couldn't do it.
And the payment for not being able to do it was that he got to put two
cigarettes out on my thumbs.
Yeah.
And I knew immediately that you're allying liar face.
Who Wise?
Because I've fucking seen cigarette burns from highschool.
I'd dumb friends that would put out cigarettes on their arms and I know what
they look like and they take weeks to heal and they puss and it's a really
gnarly,
no,
you only in Cincinnati for like four days,
Babe.
Wednesday night when I got there,
I go,
yeah,
but you can jump over this parking meter.
And I go,
yeah,
I can.
There's so much wrong with the story.
Well,
if you can't,
I'm gonna put these cigarettes out on you twice.
And I go,
all right,
man.
And I slid off the top.
I just didn't clear it by like a millimeter.
And then he put two cigarettes out on my right there.
Here's what's wrong with the story.
Number one,
you've never leapt,
jumped or skip it,
skip it.
A rinky dink over a parking meter in your life.
You've seen a photo of me doing it as a joke for a headshot when you were like
20 the photographer made you do it to make you look exciting and interesting
because in real life he would never,
never volunteered to do this thing.
Of course.
Got to find this.
It's a horrible photo.
It's so stupid and you look so dumb doing it.
Yeah.
So embarrassing.
So first of all,
that part of the story I knew immediately it was a big lie because he never leap
or jump over anything.
And number two,
I know what a cigarette burn it looks like.
Well and number three,
he put it out twice.
Okay.
Did Not hurt a lot.
Cat House was there so he saw it.
Well let's,
let's ask him then to verify your story.
We'll see if we can get them on the phone.
Okay,
let's see.
Um,
I know you're lying.
Just like you're lying about the poop pile story.
That story wasn't true either.
There's a lot of facts that don't fit your profile.
Like what?
Jumping over anything,
I've never seen you jump over anything.
You would split your pants and a second
it's not true.
Not True.
And so who who dared you to job is another part of the story.
The hotel.
This dude,
it just,
some guy was like,
hey Tom,
I feel like a little city.
It's a little,
Cincinnati is a little said no.
The where the comp,
where the hotel is.
And then some stranger.
Hey guys.
Hey Dude.
Yeah,
it's just some guy and you let some guy to cigarettes,
you know we were a little,
we're a little bit,
little toasty.
That's another part of the story that doesn't add up.
Why?
Because you don't,
you sell them.
Get
so one time I've seen you shit house drunk enough to do something that done.
Yeah.
Was that your 23rd birthday party?
20 friends when you were so drunk you were jumping rope in the bar?
Yeah.
And they had to kick you out.
And that's the one time
does it.
This call has been forwarded.
Okay,
well that's him Pat House on and he'll tell this bullshit story.
Please.
Ah Man,
you never accept dares for anything.
This would be,
so that's why they're being a little f it up,
you know,
helped.
It helped me.
It don't buy it.
You never get fucked up for Nadar.
If you've blue man,
you've been on the road with my husband,
how wasted does he get every night?
Not every night,
but you know,
I'd say like once every couple of times.
Again,
you got slow,
hammered enough to jump over a parking meter and all smiling and stuff.
You could tell he's fucked up.
Yes.
Smiling.
So that's how I know you're lying.
Number one.
That's how you're lying.
You don't get smiley and stuff and you don't act out when you're messed up.
No,
I've only seen him drunk.
I haven't seen him toasty.
Okay.
By the way,
whenever you're toasty are drunk,
you go down.
You never go up.
Me.
Yeah,
I go down.
her look at,
yeah,
I know you bro.
What do I do?
You chill.
You get,
you get more quiet and withdrawn and no,
you're not fun.
That's the whole,
thank God you're not a fun person to be around even when you're
done.
That's why I know this is such a fucking lie because you're not fun and you
don't do fun.
Things like jump over parking meters.
I know this about,
I'm not a fun place.
It's not neither of mine.
That's why we're married.
We don't like having fun.
It's rude,
really rude.
It's not rude.
I'm no fun either.
I like to do stuff.
Everyone knows that.
Oh my God.
God.
All right.
Aw.
Schedule
being on video games.
We were talking about announcers,
a video
game when they're going crazy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So anyways.
Wow.
This Koreans don't,
how much sports happening?
Huh?
Well,
I think they just really love this shit.
I mean there's a whole,
that's a whole league.
Now you the video game leads,
right?
Oh yeah.
It's really big.
And they play in arenas and people go and watch it on the big fucking deal.
Players out like six figure salary.
Okay.
This is more right.
We're done with seven figure.
Yeah.
Human race is fucking dying.
This is it.
Diseasers ams the the championship.
What the fuck is that?
Oh,
we'll save that for next week.
Okay.
All right.
Um,
is there anything else?
Jeans?
Nope,
I did.
Oh,
we have a oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
My um,
I am,
I got my
23 and me
results.
Oh,
really?
They found your park dog?
No,
I'm in the club now.
Part bear like,
I'm about to have a lot of doors open.
Okay.
Here we go.
I'm so nervous.
I am 0.3% Jewish.
Why?
Yes.
Ashkenazi Jew.
Wow.
I told my manager like I want in.
That's great.
You're so lucky you're going to,
your career's going to get even bigger now.
I know.
I want like fucking,
I want top level access now.
Like yeah,
open the doors.
I know you've been fucking leaving clothes.
Yeah.
And uh,
I had a lot of like lot of interesting thing that happens this week when I
started telling people like a lot of guys were like,
oh well you cannot,
you can come over for lunch.
Like Steven Spielberg,
take your phone call.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's really been,
it's been pretty awesome.
Yeah.
Jonah hill 0.3% but it's there.
I didn't know that.
That's really exciting.
Congratulations.
Thanks.
Yeah,
I feel like we clicked a lot more of this week to,
well it can be a head this for me by the way,
blue band was like,
well you know,
I meant to tell you something about the connection.
I feel closer and I was like,
oh,
okay.
Wow.
Does he eat jelly stuff in front of you?
Matzoh balls.
Yeah.
Do you like most ball and so lox and bagels in front of Tom.
I like locks but I love slot on eat them in front of Tom.
Is that Oh yeah,
actually at the airport.
Uh,
Pat House saw me do something very Jewish.
I put all my change into that bucket before you go into security.
Yeah.
And then I just dumped everything into my hand and pat like I turned and pat is
looking right at me and I was like,
this is the most Jewish thing I've done in like a year.
Wait.
And she kept your change or the way you look,
you need to take everything out of your pockets when you go through security.
Yeah,
like everything.
So I had like all the change from the weekend.
Right.
It's like I put my belt on it,
put my wallet in and then the last thing is the change and there's so much you
have to pick it up and dump it into my hand.
And you were like every coin,
every super self aware.
When I didn't do anything super juice.
Do you really?
You do?
Yeah.
Like us.
Jews or Jews?
Uh,
we're very aware.
I remember I was to haggle something
when,
uh,
I was at some swap meet with my friend and I'm trying to bargain the price and I
just hear my friends sign behind me.
Like,
I can't believe you're actually doing this.
They totally fucked up my deal.
I had to come back the next day.
Really?
Wow.
Interesting.
Well,
it's a whole,
it's like new stuff for me to be subconscious.
Yeah.
And like when I started doing that,
I'll be like,
eh,
Jewish.
You,
we're ready to hit your self hating Jew.
Yeah.
And also your nose is kind of Jewish.
No,
I'm serious.
Look at it.
What the fuck are you and blue man have a similar knows now that I look,
let's post a photograph.
If we can have the two profiles here.
Look how juicy you are.
Now that I look at you,
your lips are too large and you've got,
where's that?
I wish we had that drawing of the exemplary Jew from that hateful girls.
Oh yeah.
Um,
well there's a photo right there.
Yeah.
See how kind of,
you can't really tell,
but there's like a hump there.
He's us.
Your lips are big.
No racist.
Your hair's really curly or than it's ever been.
Okay.
That's really interesting.
A couple of drinks.
The top layer,
right?
Did she ask
the urine
to my bunk?
All lists or sex with your sister?
Grandmother walks on you masturbating.
Never have another orgasm
is trying to play.
Would you rather?
Right.
That's a great one.
Is that by Ali?
I did that.
I'm not sure.
What'd you rather have?
An internal and external hemorrhoid or grow ingrown toenails on both your big
totes that are also infected.
Ooh.
Where do you want pain and you asshole or your feet?
It was basically the question.
That's it.
A simple way of doing it.
Do you want your toes or your ass holder hurt all the time and,
but you know what's real sneaky about fingers and toes.
Is that when those hurt,
those really hurt?
Yeah.
You ever had any,
when you pull out the hangnail and went right,
I had one that got so infected.
You can't sleep at night if it's like throbbing in pain.
Oh,
I know.
There's a lot of pro athletes that have had their careers derailed by tow
injuries.
People don't really,
yeah,
sure.
Because if it's that bad,
if your big toe is,
you know,
you get turf toe or broken or something like that,
you can't push off of it.
You can't run,
you can't jump,
you can't do anything.
Right.
You're just in pain.
Wow.
What do you think?
What do you go for it?
Yeah,
go for it.
I've had hemorrhoids so since I was pregnant and you know,
you don't really feel them until at least I didn't until I had to go brown.
Yeah.
And I was wiping,
I remember wiping was like,
but then now with this bid day,
I mean,
yeah,
kind of by the change that I don't know,
we'll figure it out.
Um,
but I would go for the hem rights because that's only once a day or twice a day
when you're dumping like normal people,
not like you where you should every 15 minutes.
No.
I also have like I have a fear of the,
of the toe injuries and stuff.
So I think I would go,
I already have asphalt,
like excitement every day.
So I think I would,
I would take the,
those hemorrhoids oof the toes.
Toe.
The little stuff is what gets you in life.
The tone,
the fingers.
You don't want to hurt those.
Mm hmm.
Oh,
there's one,
they broke it up.
A one for me and one for you.
All right.
Tom,
would you rather wear a body suit of Burke Chrysler for one year or have
Christina where your body suit and make love to your,
how do I say,
rectum once a month for a year.
Wow.
Well,
nothing would be worse than having to be like Bart,
but uh,
that was pat
dammit.
So I tried to call him back or no,
that's up to you.
All right.
I'll call them and say,
I would absolutely make love to my own body suit that you wear over walking
around with Burt's horrific,
I think can grow better than looking like Burton and Bariatric.
Nice learning or it is a mess.
It's a big fat mess.
Big Fat mess.
Um,
Christine's a the one for you.
Would you rather a little toss Tommy Salad after he farted?
Nope.
Or shave his butthole after a devastating number six.
Shaved the bundle.
Yeah.
That's an easy one because of my mouth.
Doesn't have to go on and
silly fucking shit on my hands daily.
It's like not a problem,
Anthony.
No.
Tim and Tom,
would you rather jerk off?
Oh God.
Now blank to completion every day while he tells you how much he enjoyed the
last time you jacked him up or top dog jerk you off every day while he tells you
how much he enjoyed the last time he jacked to off.
Interesting at that is a good one.
It is.
And then it says dot,
dot,
dot.
Or be as fat and sweaty as Bert.
I walked.
Um,
this one is so horrific that I think I would dive into the most disgusting of
all choices and be Bert because clearly with dad,
I mean,
come on,
it's not going to,
I guess the real question is,
can your dad get a boner or will you get a boner?
It'd be impossible.
It would be impossible possible for your dad to give you a means.
These sessions would never end because he was like,
you gotta come,
you decided to play this game.
But then how would you get your dad heart,
man,
he's older too.
Okay.
Jeans.
Would you rather it never be able to wipe or clean your asshole for the rest of
your life?
Oh my God,
it's wine or have gnarly jacked up teeth was shipped.
Breath while missing your two fronts and never be able to fix anything.
Ah,
God I ever
put in respect on your name,
Jeremy.
Oh No,
hold on.
So you can't wipe your bum bum.
You can't clean the do off.
Yeah,
let's try to,
you can't wipe or clean up poop.
Yeah,
I'd rather do that.
You'd rather be like that.
Who's going to see my asshole?
Yeah,
but you have a shit fail.
You never wipe ever.
Yeah,
but I was taking a shower.
He didn't say I can't go in the shower and spread my cheeks and let the water do
his nation public.
It's seldom happens.
But if it does sell to just walk around with Dukie.
Yeah,
I've done it before.
You've never taken a shit that you can't wipe up.
Hence the never ending wave and why I would shit to shower.
I've taken shit so disastrous that the wipe wipe,
wipe,
wipe does it?
Sometimes there's just brown in the unaware.
You've never done that.
The Bud stamp where you leave the Brown in the underwear.
So disgusting.
Okay.
I got a call pat,
and just to wait.
I have one for you.
Well,
it's ringing.
What would you rather have sex with that old lady,
the 91 year old,
but without your face mask.
Without your,
you got to go all natural.
Yeah.
No boner pills.
100% natural.
Yeah.
You gotta look in her eyes,
you gotta be present.
You just have to look in her eyes.
No boner pills.
No virtual realities.
Yeah.
Or you can use lubricant and theater of the mind.
That's all you got.
Okay.
Or you take as many steroids.
So the guy in the opening clip and your ball shrink 50% I'm fucking aunt Edna
man.
100% rather than have your nut shrink.
But that's a good thing.
Girls like it.
Yeah.
That's what we learned by the way he like,
he's all for the illusion to,
it makes your dick look bigger like right.
Make your Dick Bigger.
It makes it look bigger in relation to your tiny child balls.
Yes.
You have a tiny deck and then kid balls.
Yeah,
it doesn't work.
Yeah.
Ridiculous.
Wait,
so you're taking the
Oh,
for sure.
Slamming her.
Thinking about that guy.
Tiny little balls.
Broken body.
Why is it so your fucking dad done answering now?
Fucking camp.
Answer your phone shit
sir.
You smell like the farts that she,
yeah,
your call.
Dude.
What is wrong with you?
My God.
I want to kill it when somebody is like,
yeah,
we can talk.
I'm telling him and he's like,
yeah,
no,
I'm calling you from another number.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
What does it take for you to answer the fucking phone?
I'm at work.
I got tables.
All right.
Listen man,
this is really important.
Sorry.
But um,
there were on the podcast right now and my wife doesn't,
I told her you were there.
She wanted to ask about those cigarettes being put out on my hand.
Oops.
Oh yeah,
I'll try the waffle house.
Yeah,
I'm sorry.
Were outside the waffle house.
Oh,
I didn't get that detail earlier.
Well,
interesting.
No,
because we went late.
This is,
I told you I've been drinking,
I've been smoking.
Waffle house is right next to the complex,
the hotel complex.
So it's like we're walking back.
There's a guy,
he's like,
I bet you can't jump over the fucking park.
And this guy,
pat described the guy.
Okay.
Describe the guy.
A white male,
50s junkie.
That's funny.
I didn't get that.
What did I leave out and say that earlier?
He was a junkie or
guy.
It was a road stops ramping it.
And you,
you had a bet going with a road stop.
A transient.
It was in the moment I was a little drunk.
I was a little high to be a lot drunk and well I wasn't,
I mean I was,
I was enough.
I was suggestible.
Yeah,
Pat.
How Fun is my husband when he's drunk or high?
Just how much fun is he at all?
Fantastic.
See Lie.
I know you're alive.
Can I tell you what she said?
You're such a liar,
but her,
her general blanket statement was,
Tom,
you're not a lot of fun.
And that's why I like being married to you.
Yeah.
You're the best husband.
Never cause you're not a lot of fun.
Yeah.
Well I disagree.
That was the highlight of my weekend.
Si.
Wow.
And how did my husband take the pain of the cigarette burns
owned it.
That's another bullshit.
Why would that be bullshit?
You don't handle pain well at all like when uh,
exactly.
Well when ivy you don't handle things like that.
You don't do that.
Some sadistic weird shit that you don't do.
You would have to be a totally different person to have this happen to you.
It was having some kind of midlife crisis.
No,
but I was just not a hundred mental illness.
I wasn't still shit.
What do you mean bullshit?
Hey Pat,
what did my husband take that night?
The led him to do that.
What did he do?
What did he take that?
Yeah.
What?
What did he drink?
We had a couple of beers and Patrona I believe.
Oh,
it's interesting because blue van said that he was high on pot blue wasn't
there?
No,
no they do.
This is a Wednesday night or Thursday that,
how did he know you were toasty?
He did.
Cause he saw me smoke.
He said when he's toasty he saw me.
He smoked the next night.
Okay.
A little like a little little toke.
Yeah.
Look man,
you have no idea how much fucking fun.
I am your so now fine.
All right.
You're never the weekend.
We'll let you go pat.
Thank you so much for,
I'm sorry I bugged you man.
But it's fine.
No problem.
Fun Time.
And thank you for being my alibi.
And my witness to the crime.
I appreciate you guys.
Absolutely.
Thanks for lying.
Sorry Buddy.
We'll talk soon.
Yeah,
there you go.
Whatever's dude,
it's a vagary.
That's funny cause you didn't mention that it was a 50 year old,
so I knew pat up vagrant.
I mean I,
I didn't leave.
I didn't give you a different description.
You're just a guy.
Yes it is.
Just the guys,
the guy,
a victor old vagrant,
like homeless junkie type.
That's a type you don't,
I mean,
not just gloss over it.
Shit's real.
I hope my cigarette burns heels aren't cigarette burns.
Dude.
Thank you guys for listening to the show jeans.
You want to add anything before we go?
You're telling me I'm a liar.
You lie to me.
Every episode,
the Poo piles a lie.
That's not a light cigarette burns.
Ally Laila,
Laila.
I can get some phone calls for the poop on it.
This is called projection.
When you project onto me what you are,
you tell him telling me I'm the liar.
You're a liar.
Okay.
Anyways,
thank you guys for listening.
Your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Please go to Tom segura.com not just for tickets to the live shows,
but for the very important,
Bert is fat shirt.
Oh,
we got to start that.
Yeah.
Those will be up soon.
Or there'll be up when you listen to this show.
Okay.
Lots of love.
We'll talk to you soon.
Bye.
Jeans.
Mommies,
right?
We go jeans.
Oh,
Shit.
No.
This is not nothing to do with you.
Yeah,
right.
I promise.
It's a surprise.
It's,
it's,
it's a surprise.
It's a surprise.
She's coming.
Just did it and we both went.
Won is incredible.
Went nuts.
I
went nuts.
I think it was towards the end.
Do in front of your mom,
your mom,
your mom.